Sometimes it's hard to remember just how humble, our humble
beginnings really were. We've used our genome cell to look
at our close and distant relatives, to discover our countries
and continents of origin even trace our maternal and paternal lines
out of Africa. But all we really need to do,
to see where we've come from, is look at the
genomes of some of our closest living relatives. One of
the best kept genetic secrets, is hiding in your chromosome two.
Now humans have 23 pairs of chromosomes, and chimpanzees
along with our other close primate relatives, like orangutans,
and gorillas, have 24 pairs of chromosomes. Now humans
and chimps are cousins. We share a common ancestor.
Now we've also shared a common habitat in Africa,
for a very long time. We look alike. We
act alike. And new tools are showing us everyday
how we even think alike but if we're so
similar to chimpanzees, then why don't we have the
same number of chromosomes? Here's an actual picture, from an
actual experiment, where somebody used a probe, a label, to
look in the genome of a human and a great
ape. These are all the chromosomes and in green
here they've painted the chromosomes that have sequences from our
human chromosome two. And you can see this chromosome lit
up in green here that's nice and long. And in
the picture of the great ape, we see the
same chromosome lit up in green, because it has
the same sequences but notice that we have twice
as many chromosomes, and they're smaller. If we were to
actually look at the sequence of our chromosome two,
it matches the sequence of two smaller chimp chromosomes. We
can even line them up side by side and
see which of the chimp chromosomes go in which order
for our human chromosome two. Humans and
chimps shared a common ancestor that lived about
six to eight million years ago and this
common ancestor likely had 24 pairs of chromosomes.
Just like all the other great apes, orangutans,
gorillas, chimps and then the population was separated
by the Great Rift Valley in East Africa.
Where the population on the west side remained
in the forest, and evolved as chimps while
the population on the east side was pushed
into the Savannah, and experienced a chromosomal fusion
during the evolution to human. Now you may find
a profound connection to parents and siblings, and
grandparents, and even great grandparents and cousins. But I
hope you take a second, to just sit
and think and share a deep appreciation for the
connection that you have with your even more distant cousin, the chimpanzee.